vediamo di uomini ma adesso temiamo che
quel che ha detto di cieli sereni
completamente opinione bianca rosa i e
ii domenica vengono perché tu mi fai
schifo
[Musica]
hey joe
muore o una chiamata di lavoro adesso
non posso parlare sono con lei
6 reti di dover amore bene anche messo
gioco e con annalisa amore allora cosa
facciamo
non lo so me web prendi la posizione
della tua vita si proprio di chi o cosa
vuoi mangiare
non lo so cosa vuoi mangiare come uguale
l'importante che tu sia felice nessuno
se lo fossero questi novellino la
partita non è solamente se riusciamo
collegati
una volta goccia permetterà di daniela
[Musica]
amore non è ancora per la tela cerata ma
perché io lavoro fresco lavorare ea
pagare a marco sono incinta vuoi fare
qualcosa anche tu per favore se l'ultima
volta che si avvia una cosa ma tu dici
capo fare ti sentivi stilizzato figlio
così esempio può esitare
[Musica]
agente di codice nel suo codice
da cui è precipitata
un figlio
no
[Musica]
cosa faccio vi scrivo l'aspetto che mi
scriva lui non sono che esisto quanto è
bello io l'uomo prima o poi ci metteremo
insieme ma forse no
[Musica]